hey guys I know the question concerning
supplements and intermittent fasting
okay what do I recommend there's a
couple things I'm going to recommend
probably one of the most important
minerals that you need when you're
intermittent fasting not just to prevent
issues like with gout or oxford stones
but just because your metabolism is
changing from glucose metabolism over to
fat burning or ketosis metabolism you
need a lot of potassium okay so
potassium is necessary and I recommend
the electrolyte powder simply because it
not only has potassium it has all
electrolytes has no multi dextran it has
a thousand milligrams of potassium
citrate which is really good to prevent
stones not just aqua stones but uric
acid stones that cause gout but it also
keep your energy up so you you're not
deficient it's also enhancement if you
just can't get all the vegetables okay
so that's one thing and I take it every
day I put it in water drink it I might
put some lemon in there then I'll do it
like twice a day especially before a
workout and it's just very very
hydrating especially if you're doing the
intermittent fasting in ketosis you're
dumping all this water you're losing
electrolytes sometimes too so you might
just need to put that back okay there's
a tiny bit of sodium in there like salt
sea salt not much it's heavy on the
potassium and the other minerals and
trace minerals so that's one thing I
recommend for the B vitamins I would get
a good nutritional yeast that's
unfortified okay make sure it's non-gmo
nutritionally you can do bruise use -
but it's a little bit bitter so
nutritional yeast and that way you can
increase the B vitamins B vitamins are
necessary to prevent that fatigue or
keto flu or the feeling like feeling
kind of heavy with lactic acid like your
legs are heavier so that will actually
because what happens is you burn fat you
generate a lot of acids so you want to
be able to take these to neutralize the
acids and even if you workout and you
have a lot of lactic acid the B vitamins
will get rid of excess
lactic acid and other assets okay so
that's what I recommend for the B
vitamins vitamins in general I basically
do the raw wheatgrass juice powder one
teaspoon is equivalent to a tray of
wheatgrass it's just the juice without
the fiber you can take this when you're
fasting but it's kind of like a coffee
substitute it will wake you up it gives
you all the vitamins and minerals it has
everything in it so I don't take a
multivitamin I take that as my
multivitamin so you can actually take
that just to make sure there's nothing
missing and then lastly this is like for
people that are really severely insulin
resistant or a diabetic or they just
want to enhance the weight loss because
it actually has 10 ingredients to
support it's called insulin and glucose
support it supports the cells that make
insulin it helps to regulate normal
insulin levels and blood sugar levels
okay so you that's another one so anyway
put your comments below and thank you so
much for watching hi guys thanks so much
for watching
press this little button down here it
says subscribe and I will make sure that
I won't send more than five to ten
videos a day okay no I'm just kidding
it'll be one or two thanks